pour en débattre nous sommes nous avec
kenneth timerman ex conseiller aux
affaires étrangères de donald trump
durant à la campagne présidentielle de
2016 bonsoir kenney timmerman merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés georges
malbrunot grand reporter au figaro
spécialiste du moyen-orient bonsoir
georges malbrunot merci aussi à vous
d'être en direct ce soir alors pas de
déclaration commune un de l'onu sur le
dossier israélo-palestinien plan à la
cessation des violences la chine
regrette l'obstruction des états unis
c'est le mot juste georges malbrunot on
a vu qu anthony blinken réfuté en ce
qualificatif
en tout cas les états unis ne veulent
pas gêner officiellement leurs efforts
diplomatiques et donc ils contre une
déclaration publique aux nations unies
on sait qu'il y à des initiatives qui
sont prises actuellement en coulisses il
y à un émissaire américain qui la bat
l'egypte le qatar également le qatar
auprès du hamas l'egypte également essai
de 2,2 de trouver les voies et moyens
pour apaiser la situation mais on a vu
que des israéliens pour l'instant
benyamin netanyahou dit non à la
diplomatie il veut ces termes en amphi
rien en tout cas continuer de on voit
bien un petit peu la stratégie c'est
après avoir après avoir beaucoup
bombardé notamment ce réseau de tunnels
qui permet au hamas de se déplacer
aujourd'hui on est plus dans une
stratégie d'élimination cibler des
dirigeants pour que et bien toute cette
campagne de bombardements produisent des
effets et que il faille attendre
quelques années avant que le hamas ne
puisse se reconstituer à la fois ses
stocks de missiles et ses essais et ses
dirigeants mais voilà on reste au jour
dans cette danse est problématique de
2,2 du glaive et du bouclier si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi tu mets la diplomatie
avance mais un petit pas qu'est la team
manager je me mêle bruno ans qui connaît
évidemment parfaitement ce dossier à
part l'élimination ciblée de la part
d'israël
il n'empêche en 200 morts pour la
plupart des palestiniens est ce que vous
vous comprenez en tant que bons
républicains malgré tout qu'il y ait
l'ouverture de ce débat y compris même
aux états unis
je suis agréablement surpris de voir la
position de l'administration bryden
d'habitude les dernières administrations
démocrates notamment oslo obama ils ont
pris parti très franchement pour les
palestiniens et anti israéliens
donc moi je mesurais réjoui de ce que je
vois maintenant de la maison blanche
ceci dit il faut comprendre au congrès
yann larges majorités bipartisanes
démocrates et républicains en soutien de
l'état hébreu c'est très très grand et
cette lettre que vous avez cités avant
qu on ouvre le débat de vingt six
membres du congrès il faut noter que
parmi les signataires il y à un somalien
qui lie à une palestiniens il ya
plusieurs supporteurs de des frères
musulmans et une vingtaine de
socialistes donc ce n'est pas comme on
dirige le centre du parti démocrate mais
vraiment l'extrême aile gauche
alors avant de servir georges malbrunot
je voudrais vous faire écouter l'un de
ses représentants un démocrate qui
critiquent cette attitude de joe biden
qui s'appelle alexandria occasion cortès
et côté là cela se produit avec le
soutien des états unis
je me fiche de la façon dont un
porte-parole essaie de tourner ça les
etats-unis ont opposé leur veto à
l'appel de l'onu pour un cessez le feu
si l'administration d'haydn ne peut pas
tenir tête à un allié acquis peut-elle
tenir tête
comment peuvent-ils prétendre de manière
crédible défendre les droits de l'homme
georges malbrunot notre ami canin petit
mort mais nous disait voilà les
démocrates ont toujours pris parti
contre l'état hébreu m'enfin là ça
serait quand même une première tenir
vraiment tête à israël de la part des
états unis
ce serait inédit n'est ce pas oui dont
je crois que
les démocrates n'ont pas vraiment tenu
tête à l'état hébreu il faut rappeler
que la dernière fois que les états unis
ont tenu tête justement à l'état hébreu
c'était en 1991 et je crois si ma
mémoire est bonne c'était george bush
père qui avait gelé les garanties
bancaires américaines au profit d'israël
pour intégrer les les juifs qui
immigraient d'union soviétique
et d'ailleurs ça avait marché ça avait
permis à israël ce avaient contraint
israël à accepter le processus de paix
qu avait été lancée à marie temps lorsqu
est intéressant au jour aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on voit qu'on sein du parti
démocrate l'ailé gauche les jeunes aussi
on en a un petit peu assez de ce soutien
peut être inconditionnel à israël que la
thématique des droits de l'homme qui a
été la thématique du parti démocrate et
joe biden durant sa campagne et bien
aujourd'hui il en est un petit peu
prisonnier puisque by one l'homme ça
veut dire qu'on revient la table des
négociations et ont négocié la fin de
l'occupation de la cisjordanie jérusalem
est ce donc ça c'est intéressant à
signaler
il ya effectivement y compris d'ailleurs
loi au sein de la communauté juive
américaine
une petite inflexion pour ne pas tomber
dans ce soutien inconditionnel
outrageusement pro israéliens comme ça
avait été le cas sous donald trump qui
était allé jusqu'à donc transférer
l'ambassade américaine de tel aviv à
jérusalem faire en sorte que les états
unis redeviennent ce qu'ils avaient
souhaité être ce qu'ils avaient prétendu
être dans l'ensemble le processus de
paix d'oslo en 1994
annonay ce broker ce qui d'ailleurs ils
n'ont jamais vraiment été puisqu'ils ont
fait toujours soutenu israël qu'elle
estimait remanié dans une drôle de
position quand même un joe biden comme
nous l'a très bien décrit georges
malbrunot il ya ce côté droits de
l'homme et il ya aussi l'opinion
américaine si on le sait est souvent
davantage pro israélienne avec une
communauté juive importante aux états
unis qu'elle peut quelle doit être
l'attitude de joe biden est ce qui peut
se prendre les pieds dans le tapis de ce
conflit écouter beaucoup denis
progressive on le voit quand on parle du
droit de l'homme et on est de gauche on
oublie
les droits des femmes en l'état
islamique de l'iran
on oublie le droit des cubains de
pouvoir voter de pouvoir s'exprimer on
oublie le droit d des hommes
on venait walla et prix de nos régimes
socialistes donc il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie quand on parle des droits
de l'homme actuellement aux etats-unis
il ya un large consensus
et ce n'est pas vous parler de la
communauté juive l'activité juive aux
etats unis c'est c'est plusieurs
millions de personnes c'est 2% de la
population
c'est pas c'est pas plus important au
nombre que la communauté d'origine arabe
mais le consensus c'est parmi l'énorme
partie des chrétiens et notamment des
chrétiens évangéliques qui soutient
israël à 80 à 90%
donc ce n'est pas ce consensus il est
réel il est n'est pas le fait d'une
partie juive de la population d'ailleurs
dans la communauté juive il ya des
organisations de gauche qui soutiennent
à l'occasion d' or qu'est ce donc même
la la communauté juive est divisé entre
israël et produisent rien
ce consensus est large va bien au delà
de la communauté juive et comprend les
chrétiens et surtout les évangéliques
aux états unis georges malbrunot
washington se défend finalement d'avoir
une approche
voilà on sous marin avec l'envoi de cet
émissaire on imagine qu'il ya beaucoup
de coups de téléphone en coulisses en ce
moment entre washington et israël et
même les territoires palestiniens est ce
que cet émissaire il peut faire
davantage de miracle qu une déclaration
sans effet à l'onu on va s'acheminer
vers une fin des hostilités
assez assez rapidement quand même parce
que vous avez vu israël il ya quelques
jours à à la déclarer l'imminence d'une
opération terrestre n'a jamais eu lieu
tant mieux parce que laisserait bien
savent très bien que c'est très
dangereux de d'or de pénétrer dans ce
petit territoire
la bande de gaza qui est densément
peuplées
donc simplement les israéliens ont des
objectifs militaires qu'il souhaite
atteindre et côté hamas et bien on veut
montrer aussi con à résister qu'on
continue de résister on est capable de
tirer en dix jours 3400 hockey ce qui
est beaucoup plus que lors de la
dernière version de 2014
donc chacun doit montrer à son opinion
publique qui là qu'il a finalement gagné
et je suis pas sûr que ce soit les
isréliens qui est vraiment gagner parce
que le hamas a montrée justement par
rapport à 2014 ou par rapport à il ya il
ya quinze ans que il avait une capacité
maintenant je dirais d'action grâce à
ces missiles qui ont une portée de
parfois 200 kilomètres plus bas qui le
qu'il instaurait un climat de tension et
de panique en israël et c'est l'objectif
qu'il recherchait donc voilà il faut il
faut qu' il faut on va en redevenant
revenir à 1-1 des nouveaux règles
d'engagement
1 il va y avoir un un cessez-le-feu
bancal qui sera conclue par l'égide sous
l'égide des égyptiens
les services de renseignement égyptiens
sont très actifs à gaza l'egypte a des
contacts avec le hamas
le qatar qui finance la bande de gaza
qui est le sponsor politique du du hamas
est appelé à la rescousse et est cotée
au trial les israéliens sont en contact
avec les américains donc on va
s'acheminer vers une vers une vers une
cessation des hostilités mais le
problème ne sera pas réglé pour autant
puisque ensuite eh bien tout ça
redeviendra entre guillemets normal la
bande de gaza qui continuera de subir un
blocus de million de palestiniens sont
dans un blocus le hamas continuera de
régner en maître sur cette bande de gaza
et le processus de paix sera toujours
dans l'impasse et c'est ça qu'il faut il
faut il faut arriver le relancer 7c'est
ces négociations pour en revenir à
l'origine du conflit c'est à dire un
conflit territorial entre israël et les
palestiniens sur l'occupation de la
cisjordanie et jérusalem est
vous êtes d'accord avec l'analyse cana
timerman
on va au final revenir au point mort ça
va être
voilà d'une certaine manière le point de
départ joe biden aujourd'hui n'est pas
l'homme de la situation comme l'a été en
son temps
bill clinton par exemple excusez moi je
rigole quand j'entends parler de
l'occupation israélienne que la cij
ordonné les italiens ils ont quitté la
cisjordanie à deux décennies ils ont
quitté gaza en 1994
je me souviens d'un voyage que j'ai fait
trois ans après elle les palestiniens
disait toujours il pouvait pas
reconstruire il pouvait rien faire à
cause de l'occupation israélienne il n'y
avait pas un juif sur le territoire de
gaza
à l'époque donc c'est un peu à un
barbare de parler de l'occupation
mais georges malbrunot je vais où je
vous fais répondre sera peut-être pas
refaire le pont suis parce que voilà la
base du débat cette fille le rôle des
états unis mais pas de nier l'histoire
israël a occupé gaza sont les retirer en
2005 israël continuait d'occuper la
cisjordanie et jérusalem est
voilà ce n'est pas être pro anti ou je
ne sais quoi c'est un fait historique
c'est tout voilà donc on peut pas
contester saint memmie serait ne le
conteste pas alors je vais vous faire
écouter bernis la wii quantité de
territoire que d'israël occupa c'est
vraiment mener des scud mais il ya une
chose importante vous n'a pas évoqué
c'est le soutien de l'iran le soutien
liront à gaza est la raison que hamas a
les roquettes qui sont capables a tiré à
tel-aviv et au nord d'israël c'est grâce
à dire en les iraniens ont cette
capacité de se battre jusqu au son du
dernier libanais ils ont montré ça en
et là ils vont se battre jusqu'au sang
du dernier palestinien est large avec
vous non c'est pour ça qu'il faut que le
vigile faut qu'ils fassent la paix le
hamas a été en bisbille avec l'iran au
cours de ces dernières années était en
conflit parce que le hamas soutenait les
rebelles syriens contre bachar el assad
alors que l'iran était
ami de bachar al assad les encore et
simplement comme les rebelles anti
syriens ont perdu l'iran a été aux bleus
le hamas a été obligé de revenir un
petit peu je dirais piteusement à
téhéran pour que téhéran continue
effectivement de lui envoyer les
instructeurs militaires d'êta donc la
puye iranien il est effectivement du
hezbollah et de l'iran il est il et il
est évident et il est à il est
regrettable
bien sûr j'étais correspondant à
jérusalem il ya vingt ans des roquettes
du hamas elle avait 2 km de portée la
nature ayant horreur du vide aujourd'hui
les en jeu je dirais 100 fois plus 7 200
km non le moralité il faut revenir au
processus de paix le statu quo pauline
le statu quo n'est pas supportable et il
faut continuer à avancer vers cette
solution des deux états un état
palestinien qui vit aux côtés d'israël
dans des frontières sûres et reconnues
en sécurité voilà il n'y a pas d'autre
solution sinon on recommencera se débat
dans en trois ans ou dans cinq ans et le
hamas aura des roquettes ils seront
encore plus performante et égayent gaza
renault pape 2 millions d'habitants mais
trois millions de litres il sera encore
plus dangereux pour l'état hébreu
oui il faut avoir un parti qui veulent
faire la paix quand vous avez une des
partie le hamas qui prêchent pas
seulement l'extermination de l'état juif
mais l'extermination des juifs
il n'y a pas possibilité de négociations
ont donné qu'on ne négocie pas avec
quelqu'un qui verront comment votre
extermination et pas vous
personnellement mais toute votre race to
votre peuple c'est à dire le génocide
normal c'est un c'est un mouvement
génocidaire malbrunot c'est l'un des
points d'achoppement effectivement
le hamas qui est tout de même considérée
comme une organisation terroriste sur
les listes de l'union européenne est ce
qu on négociait ce qu'on peut négocier
effectivement avec le hamas j'allais le
hamas les israéliens le connaît sur le
bout des doigts parce que il l'est ils
ont en partie formé entre 1967 et 1987
lorsque pour contrer l'ol paie dias et
ils ont laissé les islamistes les
mosquées se construire à gaza ensuite
lorsque la masse a été créée en 1987 la
plupart des dirigeants étaient
emprisonnés en israël et donc les
israéliens le shin bet a interrogé je me
souviens d'avoir rencontré cheikh ahmad
yassine des dizaines de fois peut-être
pas des dizaines mais enfin en tout cas
oui plusieurs dizaines de fois et il
avait fait de la prison en israël
ses collaborateurs aussi par les
protecteurs très bien le hamas il faut
le hamas n'est pas un mouvement
djihadiste
il est un mouvement terroriste dont son
combat contre israël
il a évolué sur un certain nombre de
points y compris dans la reconnaissance
des frontières israélienne de 1967
et effectivement il vient bien sûr c'est
un mouvement un mouvement terroriste
mais si personne ne lui parle eh bien il
va se retourner encore plus vers l'iran
donc il ya bien un moment donné aussi il
faut ça bien il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut de cette bande de gaza et les
palestiniens qui vont survivre soit
bande de gaza loin s'en faut ne sont pas
tous pour le hamas qui exercent
justement une mini dictature sur eux
mais il faut ré ouvrir cette bande de
gaza il faut trouver une solution
diplomatique économique pour ces
palestiniens et le hamas à partir de la
perdra de son aura perdra de son
influence il faut aussi que l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas
à 85 ans qui aujourd'hui est
complètement carbonisé accepte de passer
la main qui est nouvelle génération
palestine bien que les israéliens libère
marwan barghouti et d'autre
là il faut tout ça et n'est pas
inenvisageable mouvement le hamas un
syndrome de pays la norvège la suisse
discute avec avec lui un certain nombre
de pays arabes il faut faire évoluer les
choses
encore une fois la nature a horreur du
vide le statu quo est intenable et
on attend plus d'eux des radicaux au
sein du hamas vont prendre le peuvent
prendre le pouvoir
on a assisté à l'émergence c'est cette
dernière décennie dans sur la frange
dirais à droite du hamas si on peut dire
ça de gens qui sont venus jihadistes ils
sont allés combattre avec l'état
islamique neige dans le sinaï
non voilà il faut bien sûr que le hamas
s'est pas des gens avec l'ailé qu'alors
on on irait passer nos vacances mais ils
sont là ils ont été créés sont
développés et ont prospéré sur le la
pauvreté sur l'impasse diplomatique
et bien aujourd'hui il faut il faut il
faut relancer un processus diplomatique
qui permettrait donc de dégonfler et de
réduire leur influence sur la société
palestiniens et leurs capacités
merci à tous les deux le georges
malbrunot kenneth timerman d'avoir
accepté ce face à face en direction arte
france merci à vous